the motion picture in the Year 1961
became a part of international diplomacy
movies were made in Greece France India
and Russia with political implications
and even here in Hollywood the word from
Desilu studios was Cuba see Sinatra no
but there's one man who knows more about
the international situation than even I
do or desi arnaz the movie industry's
roving ambassador president of the
Motion Picture Association of America
mr. Eric Johnson
thank you Bob I'm glad Pope's back on
earth even though he landed that the
golf course in Washington after Yuri
Gagarin did in Russia once again it is
my privilege to present the Foreign
Language Film Award very often the films
of this category need less translation
than our own now why is that because
they are simple and much to the point in
clinical terms they choose a single
subject they proceed to probe to enquire
to speculate they assemble a body effect
and they reach a conclusion this year
the Academy received entries from 12
foreign countries and the five five
films nominated are from Italy couple by
Vitas zebra film generis from France la
vérité by hon production from Mexico
Macario by class of films Mundi Ali's
from Yugoslavia the ninth circle by
Jacques Grande film from Sweden the
Virgin spring by AV Spence film industry
the winner is
Oh the winner is a virgin spring
Tyra's gay party
I'm proud to accept on behalf of Spence
Co ministry and all those responsible
for the Virgin spring
Ingmar Bergman the director will at East
auction the screenwriter
dr. Kyle Anders demoing the producer
Topsham weakened